Speaker 1: So there's just one more aspect
of yesterday's completely clown car humiliating
Twitter hearings that Republicans orchestrated
now that they control the House of Representatives
that I want to look at separately.
And it is about the snowflake triggered nature
of the failed former President Donald Trump,
who tried to get a tweet from celebrity Chrissy
Teigen about him removed from Twitter.
Now, there is some strong language in this
segment.
I'm giving you fair warning even before I
get to it.
I'm just letting you know that there is strong
language in this segment.
One of the stories that has been told by the
right is that the Biden administration, which
of course, was not in administration at the
time, it was it was a campaign, was demanding
content be removed from Twitter simply because
it was disadvantageous to Joe Biden.
Now, when you evaluate that claim, what you
find out is that the Biden administration
wanted explicit images of Hunter Biden shared
without his consent against Twitter terms
of service and a crime in most states removed.
And that was absolutely legitimate.
But we have now found out that there was a
tweet which just was insulting to Trump that
he wanted removed.
Here is Congressman Frost speaking to Twitter
executives about this.
Again, there is strong language here.
Listen to what it was that Trump wanted removed
from Twitter.
Speaker 2: Ms.. Nervously.
Earlier, you testified about a 2019 tweet
that was about President Trump.
And I think it's from Mr. Keegan.
What was the tweet about?
Speaker 3: Would you like me to give the direct
quote?
Yeah.
Please excuse my language.
This is a direct quote by Chrissy Teigen.
Referred to Donald Trump as a pussy aspect.
Speaker 2: Of free speech.
And what happened after Ms.. Teigen posted
her tweet?
What did the White House do?
What did the Trump White House do?
Speaker 3: For my understanding, the White
House reached out to ask that this tweet be
removed.
Speaker 1: Now, folks, that's not a campaign.
That's an administration.
That is government.
Calling Twitter, emailing Twitter, sending
a smoke signal to Twitter and saying, remove
the speech of this private citizen on a private
platform.
Speaker 3: It was my team's job, the spell
underneath the policy for abusive behaviors.
And we evaluate it underneath our insults
policy.
At that time, up to three insults were allowed.
And so it was our job to determine how many
insults were included within that phrase.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 2: Right.
White House reached out to not an agency,
but the White House reached out and requests
that you remove the tweet.
Speaker 3: For my understanding, yes.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
That is the epitome of these right wingers.
The left wants everything censored.
Well, they want images that are a crime censored.
But you want Chrissy Teigen censored because
she called you names.
And the irony is that Trump's attempt to censor
the tweet reinforces the accuracy of Chrissy
Teigen's tweet.
That's the amazing thing.
They say Twitter's censoring conservatives
while they are demanding that liberals be
censored for opinions that are of no national
security implication, they're not doxing anybody.
Nobody's at risk.
Nobody is in danger.
Trump has the best protection ever.
Even if someone saw Chrissy Teigen's tweet
and they wanted to go and do something to
Trump, it is the theme of authoritarian narcissists
being very thin skinned people like Trump.
And we can look in history and find other
examples.
They see statements.
They see criticism like this as a threat to
their power and their ego.
Hitler, Stalin, Kim Jong un, just to name
a few.
They all had the same personality trait.
Hitler, as the leader of Germany, was infamous
for his sensitivity to criticism, and he saw
media as a tool for propaganda.
He would suppress criticism of his regime,
he would censor newspapers, he would jail
journalists because these authoritarian narcissists
see themselves as threatened by any kind of
criticism.
Another example, Josef Stalin, former leader
of the Soviet Union.
Stalin would brutally repress dissent.
He would imprison and sometimes execute critics
and political opponents.
He saw criticism as a direct threat to his
rule, and he did everything he could to silence
it.
And then more recently in North Korea, Kim
Jong un.
And there's more.
It goes earlier than just Kim Jong un, Kim
Jong Il and others, but an authoritarian leader
who is so thin skinned, Kim Jong un, notorious
for strictly controlling information, suppressing
dissent and doling out severe punishment for
criticism of the regime.
Trump is not Hitler, Stalin or Kim Jong un,
but Trump has that same authoritarian, narcissistic
tendency that they do.
And it's embarrassing and it's pathetic.
And again, allegations are confessions.
The left is trying to censor our speech.
They're not.
But you're trying to censor the left's speech.
That's what we keep learning.